hi Brian most interesting idea I've
heard today at has tooth globalization I
think that so many folks that are here
are thinking about how globalization is
changing in the world economic forum for
the last 40 years has really been the
sort of archetype of the International
promoter of globalization but we think
about it's like the world's getting
closer yet of course that's really not
what's happening it's really hot with
globalization is the West countries in
the West multinational corporations and
West have reached out to multinational
corporations they've reached out to
consumers that reach out to laborers and
they brought that labor they're
manufactured goods they're our prophets
I thought those countries closer to the
West it's been a process really of the
West reaching out and bringing back and
I think what's so interesting about this
year the economy is coming back the
world is clearly doing better people
feel a lot more confident and
comfortable about where the world
economy is heading and how they're doing
personally and yet the wefts notion of
globalization and to be very clear it's
still very much primarily the West is
represented at this year's forum is no
longer the way globalization is actually
proceeding globalization's increasingly
about all sorts of countries around the
world doing their own forms of
international outreach and some of that
is to the advanced economies a lot of it
is to their own regions a lot of us to
other developing countries that's really
changing in Benitez's globalization
which had been on one track around the
world that that was very much found here
at the World Economic Forum is now on a
couple of different tracks and the track
that's represented here is increasingly
not the track that we see in so many
other countries and I think that's
causing despite all of the upbeat
optimism about the world economy it's
against the backdrop of uncertain
seeing our knees and I don't think we're
getting rid of that anytime soon thanks
a lot for your question what was
interesting